WILLIAM FLOYD: Please, join
me in giving a warm welcome
to Bonita Stewart
and DeRay McKesson.
[APPLAUSE]
BONITA STEWART: [INAUDIBLE].
Well, thank you, William,
for just the introduction
to this very special talk
that we have this afternoon.
I am personally excited
to sit next to DeRay
because he's just had such an
impact in one way or another
in all of our lives.
So DeRay, let's just start--
you've had an incredible
personal journey.
You follow things that
you're most passionate about.
So I saw where you actually were
in the public school system,
human resources official there.
But tell us about
your personal journey.
And we talked about
being born in Baltimore
or spending time in Minnesota.
But how did you follow
all of these passions?
How did you set
out on this path?
DERAY MCKESSON: So
I'll start by saying
it's an honor to be here.
It's great to be here.
It's always a joy to
talk about this work.
I do wish though
that we didn't have
to spend so much time fighting
systems and structures that
were killing us so we could
go do the cool things that
make us joyous about the world.
So I'm mindful of that.
I think about this.
I was in student government
my whole childhood,
and that was really
important to me.
Both of my parents
were addicted to drugs.
My mother left when I was
three and she came back
when I was 30.
I just turned 33--
this is my Jesus year.
[LAUGHTER]
WILLIAM FLOYD: Amen.
DERAY MCKESSON: My
mother left, yeah.
So she just came back a couple
of years ago-- three years ago.
And my father got clean when
I was around three or four.
And I think about that
because in so many ways,
I grew up in a
community of recovery.
I grew up seeing people
put their lives back
together in ways that
they didn't always think
was possible.
And that was childhood for me.
I'll never forget coming
down from my bedroom one day
and I see this guy
sitting on the couch.
And I'm like, he
looks really familiar.
And it was one of
my sister's friends.
And I'm like, why is he in
our house in the morning--
why is he on the couch?
And he was recovering and
my father was counseling him
during recovery.
I have so many memories of that.
And I think about
that all the time,
because I know what it's
like to see communities
break and come back together.
And I think about this
work and resistance
is seeing things break
and believing that they
can come back together.
But I taught, and
teaching was probably
the single coolest,
most important,
magical thing I've ever done.
I taught sixth grade math here
in the East New York, Brooklyn.
And sixth grade is beautiful.
Seventh grade is
puberty and deodorant,
but sixth grade is still--
[LAUGHTER]
--a lot of magic.
If you've never been
in a group of kids
who don't know they
need deodorant,
that is seventh grade.
Sixth grade is a lot of joy.
And I'll never forget,
one day I was--
I taught 69 in 120
minute classes,
which is a long time for a
11-year-old to do anything, let
alone math.
And they were like,
can we go to gym early?
And I'm like, absolutely,
you can go to gym early.
I'm tired of you,
you're tired of me.
We've been together
for a long time.
First, second, third,
fifth, and seventh period--
this one class.
So I let them go.
And they come back
really quickly
and they're back
in my classroom.
I'm like, why are
you back so quick?
And I realize that they're
in love with the idea of gym
more than the work of gym.
And I say that because
in moments like this,
I think people are more in love
with the idea of resistance
than the work of resistance.
And the question for me now--
four years after we were in the
streets initially in Ferguson,
it's like, what does
the work look like?
How do we use spaces like this--
if we ever are going to just
keep talking about it--
to actually force people to
engage in the work and not just
the conversation
of these things?
So I got into it because
my friend got killed.
I was on my couch and I
was like, this is crazy.
So I'm going to go and the
least I can do is just go
for the weekend.
I was like, I'm going to
out for Saturday and Sunday.
And I went, and
the second night I
was in St. Louis was the
first night I got tear gassed
and I was like, this is wild.
I'll do whatever I can to
make sure that nobody else has
to experience this.
So I quit and did all
these other things.
And in hindsight now
I'm like, that was--
like, what was I doing.
But I did it and so many
other people did it.
I'm proud that I was
not the only person.
There were so many
incredible people
in St. Louis who did whatever
they could to make a difference
and continue to do that work.
WILLIAM FLOYD: As a
father of a 12-year-old,
I can attest, yes,
deodorant is big deal.
DERAY MCKESSON: It's real.
[LAUGHTER]
And you don't want to
hurt their feelings,
so you're like,
hey, that smell--
free gifts for class.
WILLIAM FLOYD: Exactly.
I have to stand over
him in the bathroom.
Like, [INAUDIBLE]---- But you
mentioned a little earlier
about your personal experience
with communities breaking
and re-knitting them together.
How does technology
play a role in that
from your point of view?
DERAY MCKESSON: So two things.
One is the platforms and
the second is the people,
like you all, who make
these things real.
When I think about Twitter--
if not for Twitter,
Missouri would
have tried to convince
you that we didn't exist.
Literally, if we had not been
able to tell our own stories
in real time, they
would have been like,
those people aren't
really out there.
And you're like,
are you kidding?
People forget that in August,
September, and October of 2014,
it was illegal to stand
still in St. Louis.
So if you saw us
marching, it wasn't only
that marching was a
really cool thing to do,
it was the five-second rule.
So if you sit still for
more than five seconds,
you were arrested.
And we remember that
because that was crazy to us
and that was real.
And we just adjusted.
We sued them and it got
deemed unconstitutional.
But if not for--
I remember my tweet about
the five-second rule
was the first public recorded
instance of the rule.
So when we sued them,
I had to testify.
And literally the judge
is like, what is Twitter?
And I'm like, it's Twitter.
He's like, what is a tweet?
And we're literally
recounting my tweet thread
about the five-second rule.
And if not for
social media, we just
wouldn't have been
able to do that.
Jack the CEO of
Twitter is a friend
and I remember getting a
call from him being like,
DeRay, we're going to
buy this company that
is called Perioscope
because we don't have any--
I remember that call,
but that was late.
We'd already been in--
all we could use was Vine.
So in the beginning,
we'd literally--
we'd record a video
on our iPhones.
Then we'd go run off to the
side, upload it in Vine,
and scroll through trying to
find the best six seconds,
and then post it online.
That was our strategy to do,
because there was no Twitter
Video, there was
no Facebook Live,
there was no YouTube streaming.
Those things didn't
exist back then.
And there are critics of
us who will say things
like, you chased the cameras.
And we're like, we
were the cameras.
We were it.
We were the people
telling the truth.
The second part of this--
it was like the people
in places like this--
I'm always mindful that
people made these things.
These things don't just
emerge out of thin air.
And what I found over
four years is that when
we think about leaders--
we often get leaders,
whether they're
leaders in the country, not
this guy, but other people,
or leaders of companies--
and they do things like,
we're everybody's CEO.
We don't just lead
the black people
or the black and
brown people, we're
everybody-- they use that
language as if that's supposed
to be some inclusive statement.
But the reality would be if
you were everybody's CEO,
you would be marshaling
and marching white people
to a vision of
equity and justice.
Because that would be what
leadership looks like.
I think what you
find in places--
I've definitely seen tech
companies hide behind
this vision of inclusivity that
is actually not about equity,
it's not about justice, but it's
this idea that tech is neutral.
You're like, none of
this stuff is neutral.
So I worry about what that
looks like in companies
across the tech community.
And the second is, what
is people's proximity
to these issues?
So you see a lot of
companies who are like,
we care and da, da, da.
There are a lot of people
who think the country got bad
with the Muslim ban.
And the country has
been bad way before--
the Muslim ban is bad.
That is not the beginning
of the bad, though.
Or it takes a tragedy
hitting one set of employees
for people to be like,
oh, my god, the country.
And you're like, how close
are you to these issues
that you say you
care about everyday?
And we actually
can be using tech
to do something really
interesting and cool about.
I worry about what
that looks like.
As somebody who's not in tech,
I know what the issues are.
I want to believe that if people
who knew how to do something
in a tech space-- just
knew the issues better,
they'd be able to
help us brainstorm.
So you think about, what
does it mean in California
that 1 in 11 homicides is
committed by an officer
or a third of all
the people killed
by a stranger in this
country is actually
killed by a police officer?
Those are wild things.
And want to believe
that we could figure out
how to capture data better
or we could figure out how
to visualize this stuff better.
If you get killed in this
country and a newspaper
doesn't write about
you, you literally
are not in the dataset--
you don't exist.
So any number you've ever
heard about police violence
comes from the aggregate
of newspaper reports.
There are two years in
Florida recently that they
reported no killings by police.
You're like, well, we
know that's not true.
That's just a lie.
So how do we help people
like you get close enough
to the issues so you can help us
brainstorm real systemic things
to do something about it?
BONITA STEWART: So
it's interesting
when you think about
a role of technology.
My husband always jokes--
he said, who would have
thought Steve Jobs--
if he only knew that he was the
original purveyor of justice.
Because with the
invention of the mobile--
the iPhone was a real start.
And then aggregating
all of the apps,
such as Twitter and
Instagram and YouTube--
all of this in
terms of technology
and putting it in
the hands of people.
You talk a little
bit about the truth.
And there's different
sides of it.
One, in terms of now
everyone is carrying
the device, the device
that can either speak
to truth or in some cases--
one of the areas that
we're focused on,
which we announced with
the Google News initiative
is around media literacy,
so that people understand
what is the truth, being
a big supporter of quality
journalism.
So how are you thinking
about technology
and driving the truth?
And what role, quite
frankly, could we
play as a technology company?
Because now there's things that
are popping up because people
have the devices.
And we could probably
turn on the news tonight
and there will be some
story about someone
that has been
recorded, and they're
trying to explain the truth.
And I do think particularly with
under-represented minorities,
quite frankly, that becomes,
for us, a source of truth.
So how are you thinking about
the literacy, the truth,
and then the technology
all combined?
DERAY MCKESSON:
Yeah, so we never
want to confuse
awareness for action.
Understanding the problem
is a part of the work
and seeing that the
world is screwed up
has to be the first step.
There are some people
who think that that
is the whole equation, though.
We just know that
that is not true.
Especially four
years later, if you
see another video of the
police killing somebody,
if you're shocked now,
it's like, where were you?
That is not necessarily a
special thing in this moment.
What we'd also say though
is that there are people who
have yet to understand that
this is not a system of chances,
this is not a
system of constance,
this is a system of choices.
The best thing that we
can do is help people
see what those choices were
that have been made before
to set us up to make a
different set of choices.
That is what we think
is really important.
So we think about the
police as an example.
Four years ago I
would have been like,
it's a screwed up
system with bad people
making bad decisions.
Now I'm like, the
game is just rigged.
So you look at California--
California has a law that
says any investigation
of an officer that lasts
more than a year can never
result in discipline
regardless of the outcome.
That just doesn't make--
that's like a
different set of rules.
In Cleveland,
disciplinary records
are destroyed after 60 days.
After one year,
different set of rules.
We're just not actually
playing the same game.
And what we've started to do
is help people figure out,
here's a game
that's being played.
I think that's one of the things
that the right does really
well.
They're very quiet
about it, but they just
change the playing field.
We have been seduce to believe
that the best argument wins--
if we make the best
case and da, da, da.
The best argument doesn't win.
The argument that's
beat into people's
head over and over,
that is what wins.
I think that we've forgotten
how to do that sometimes.
When I think about
the role of tech,
I think there's some huge
data things that people
could be working on.
So you've probably heard people
talk about bail reform and all
this stuff with bail.
There's actually
very little data
about bail-- it
just doesn't exist.
So we know that when people go
before the judge or the bond
hearing or whatever, that
there's a stenographer taking
down everything.
But that the only place that
the bail amounts are recorded.
So you've never seen a
study on bail by judge.
You've never seen
a study on bail
by any demographic indicator,
because there is no data.
So there's a ton of stuff
where there's just not data,
but we know these
issues are things.
If I ask you right now, what's
a felony, what would you say?
WILLIAM FLOYD: What's
the technical definition
of a felony?
DERAY MCKESSON: Give me
an example of a felony.
WILLIAM FLOYD:
Breaking and entering.
DERAY MCKESSON:
WILLIAM FLOYD: Stealing a car.
DERAY MCKESSON: Stealing a car.
That, to a certain extent.
What would about you?
BONITA STEWART: If you
were robbing a bank.
DERAY MCKESSON: Robbing a bank.
Well, you ask most
people, what's a felony,
they say these big things.
They're like, blowing up a
building, killing 10 people,
robbing a bank.
In Virginia, up until this year,
theft over $200 is a felony.
In Florida, to this day,
theft over $300 is a felony.
And in both of those states,
when you become a felon,
you permanently lose
the right to vote.
That is wild.
We've been conditioned
to think about felons
as people who have
killed 10 people, smiled,
and taken a picture.
That's what you
think about a felon.
A felony is stealing
a Chromebook, an iPod.
That is how people are being
disenfranchised and get scaled.
But that's actually not the
story that you hear the most.
In Oklahoma, up until 2001,
theft over $50 was a felony.
So the way that we've
been conditioned
to think about these
problems is a real issue.
So what we would say is that
people in tech, people who know
how to look at aggregate data--
the more that we can uncover
and unearth these things
and visualize them
in a way that helps
people realize that the only
radical thing is the fact
that we are talking about it.
The fact that we're
fighting the system
is not the radical piece.
The fact that we have
to fight the system
is the crazy radical
thing in the first place.
But there are all
these minor things
that people just don't know.
The last thing I'll say is,
how many people are on a jury?
This is not a trick question.
WILLIAM FLOYD: I have been.
DERAY MCKESSON: How many people?
No, how many?
WILLIAM FLOYD: Oh, how many?
12.
DERAY MCKESSON: He's
like, I was one.
Yes.
[LAUGHTER]
BONITA STEWART: It's
like, "12 Angry Men."
That's how you can remember it.
DERAY MCKESSON:
There are two states
in the country where it only
takes 10 of the 12 people
to convict you of a felony.
So in Louisiana, you can
get convicted with life
without the possibility
of parole in a 10-2 vote,
which is so wild.
In Louisiana, it's directly
tied to integration.
That when black people
started sitting on juries,
they literally held a
constitutional convention
so they could
change the threshold
so that black people would never
be able to lower the conviction
rate.
It's Louisiana and Oregon.
In Oregon, it was about Jews.
Oregon is the only state
that banned black people
from living in the state.
They had already
discriminated against some,
so juries weren't the
best way to do it.
But they did it for Jews.
That is nuts.
So to this day, in
Louisiana right now--
and hopefully it'll get changed
in November because it'll be up
at the ballot--
it only takes 10 people.
And I only found
out because I did
a 6-hour tour of Angola,
which is the biggest prison
complex in the country.
And I was I was asking one of
the inmates, what don't I know?
And he was like, you probably
don't know that it only takes
10 people to send us here.
That is nuts.
There are these
structural things
that don't make the
public conversation,
but actually are bringing
more people into the net.
And we don't talk about those.
We try to spend more time on
those things now than the stuff
that you see everyday
in the newspaper.
WILLIAM FLOYD: Your comment
about awareness and action--
our forum today is actually
to tie those two together.
Because you're right,
education and awareness--
we're beyond that.
And I speak
personally, and I think
for many Googlers
in the room, they're
looking for ways to
connect and to drive
their awareness
and their outrage
into something that's
very constructive.
Case in point, you
wrote the thing
about technology and data.
I think one of the
organizations that's
here today that's tabling
outside after our talks is
the Vera Institute of Justice.
DERAY MCKESSON:
Yeah, we love Vera.
WILLIAM FLOYD: Yeah.
I sit on the board of the
Vera Institute of Justice.
And Google is
partnering with Vera
to do a project to
illuminate and bring out
how mass incarceration actually
is being driven by smaller
regional, smaller jurisdictions
around the country, not
the big cities.
Actually, the big cities
are doing the lot,
either because they got
woke or they realize they
don't have the money to do it--
to deemphasize incarceration.
It's actually the
smaller jurisdictions
around the country, mostly in
red states and rural areas,
that, in the aggregate, is
driving up mass incarceration.
And our thought is let's
get the data out there.
Let's go out and educate
politicians and those folks who
live in those communities
on how they're actually
contributing to this overall
emphasis on incarceration.
Just wanted to make that plug.
But I did want to ask you a
question though about stories
and surfacing stories, which
you do in your podcast.
To Bonita's point
about media literacy--
there's a role there of
surfacing news stories that
are actually getting suppressed
because of the deluge of what
we're reading in the
newspapers that are important.
Can you tell us a
little bit about that,
like some stories that
you've recently come across?
DERAY MCKESSON: Yes.
The podcast is called
"Pod Save The People."
Shout out to Sam.
Sam is on the podcast, too.
Sam is here-- love Sam.
So when I started the
podcast a year ago,
I wanted the first half to be
about all the news you don't
know that's really important.
You're going to hear about Trump
whether you want to or not.
So we didn't feel like we needed
to spend a whole lot of time
on him, because you're
going to hear him anyway.
The way it works
is the four of us--
everybody picks their
piece of news every week,
they put it in the group chat.
We don't hear your argument
about the news until we record.
So we're learning
when you say it.
And there's some
things-- there was
a study that says that there's
pushing back on the idea
that people get more
conservative as they get older.
And what the study is saying
is that poor people and people
of color actually
just never get older.
So it's not that people are
getting more conservative,
it's that some people just never
have the luxury of getting old.
And you're like, hadn't
thought about that--
that's really interesting.
Or on the news tomorrow--
you probably heard
about the straw ban in Seattle.
People talk about it as
a really important thing
for the environment.
The disability community
is really frustrated
because there are people with
disabilities who needs straws.
And when you have now
made straws illegal,
what happens for people
who can't use their hands,
for people who need
disposable straws?
A permanent straw is not
actually the most hygienic
for a set of people.
So trying to look at these
issues that people take for
granted and look at them
from a different angle.
The straw story is
really interesting, too,
because it's all predicated on
this study that says that we
use 500 million straws a day.
When you ask about
the study, the study
comes from a nine-year-old
who did a phone survey.
[LAUGHTER]
That literally is the
source of the study.
So Snopes and everybody
has tried to figure out,
what's the source of the study?
And the guy's like, I
did it when I was nine.
He's 16 now and
people are like--
every major news organization
has cited this study
as 500 million straws a day.
And you're like, uh--
was that a science fair project?
Where did the straw
study come from?
So we try and look at these
issues from a different angle,
hopefully setting listeners up
with a different set of skills
to be able to ask
questions and think
about things in a way they
might not have otherwise.
And then we give interviews.
Tomorrow is Ocasio-Cortez, who
is a big deal here in New York
and across the country.
And she was even more
impressive in person.
We're going to have to
edit some of the interview
because it was an hour and
the whole podcast is an hour.
But I asked her this
question about her mom.
I'm like, was your mom
there on election day?
And she's like, yeah,
my mom was there.
And there wasn't really a
story about election night.
She was like, my mom
stayed the next day,
and she's like, I was
doing all this media--
this is more media
than I've ever
done so I wasn't at the house.
And she's like, my mom
calls and is like, hey,
the "New York
Post" just came by.
She's like, OK, how was it?
She was like, oh, chill
interview-- not a big deal.
And she's like, OK.
Next day, front
page of the "Post"
is, Ocasio-Cortez
running for president.
And she was like, mom,
what did you say to them?
And she's like, I told them my
baby could be present one day.
[LAUGHTER]
She's like, never,
ever talk to the press.
You're banned.
If people-- just tell
them I'm not home.
She had other things
to say about politics.
But I thought she
was so great with it.
But it was this conversation
when I started the podcast
about, how do we invite
people into conversations
that they might not
be a part of before?
So Ocasio-Cortez, we had
Snowden on really early.
He was the third interview I did
to talk about the intersection
of security and race.
Because Snowden doesn't
really talk about race.
But I wanted to
create a space so we
can talk about what race
looks like in the security
conversation.
And those sort of
things-- we wanted
to be a home and a place led by
activists, where we could just
say what we want that
we believe is true.
BONITA STEWART: If
you have questions,
this is an opportunity
to start lining up
and then we have a few
more questions for DeRay.
I want to just circle back
on the law enforcement.
We talked about
podcasts and audio
and the importance of audio.
But now, technology is
coming to police enforcement.
How do you think from an audio
perspective and technology--
the fact that this is now
being captured with video,
there's audio.
What is your view of the
technology in the law
enforcement and how you think
it will be used or not used?
Or the consequences we were
talking earlier about--
are there consequences based
on now having actual proof?
DERAY MCKESSON: So
I think technology
has been in policing for better
or for worse for a long time.
I think body cameras
are the newest
iteration that most people
have public language about.
When the Obama administration
was still in play,
we had been talking
to their team.
They were partnering
with the university
to figure out if they could
use the audio specifically
to measure aggression
in an officer's voice.
So not just looking
at the video,
but could we see spikes in
temper and things like that
just by the audio?
Which is an interesting
way to think
about using body cameras that
don't just rely on the footage.
So that's an interesting thing.
I think we should follow-up
and see where they are.
There is new
technology, too, that
allows to trigger
the body cameras,
like, when a police
door opens, things
like that, that don't
require the officer
to press a button
anymore, but just
automatically turn on the
dash cam or things like that.
We're in the minority
in the movement
conversation about cameras.
Because a lot of people rightly
are nervous about body cameras
as being another
tool of surveillance.
That if community policing
really is your code for putting
police in black neighborhoods--
because they're not going to be
on the Upper West Side in the
same way you're putting them
in other places--
and if community policing
becomes this idea
that the police need to know
my kid's name not to kill them.
You don't need to play football
with my child not to kill him.
But that is how people use this
idea of community policing.
If that is the case, you
put cameras on people
and now you just are surveilling
the whole neighborhood.
So that is not a good thing.
What is interesting
about the video thing
is that in the 1%
of police officers
who are ever charged
with anything,
videos are actually
really important.
So that's where you get stuck.
It is the likelihood
of you getting
charged without a video--
it's probably not happening.
The video is our
only slight pathway
to there being some
sort of accountability,
which is why we veer to
video rather than not video.
Which is a complicated
piece about it.
With all the technology
used in policing,
we believe that there
should be public oversight.
So what you find
in a lot of cities
is that the body camera
footage is actually
under the purview of
the police department.
Only the police department.
Nobody has access to it.
We don't believe that
that is a just way
to think about
any of this stuff.
And that is really hard.
So I that we're
in this new space
where people now
have the language
to talk about the technology.
But the police would advocate
for all types of stuff.
They want facial recognition.
It's like, y'all aren't
solving any crimes any better.
None of that's going to build
the trust that you broke.
And you broke the trust.
I'm not convinced
technology is going
to be the salve
for how you rebuild
that trust in communities,
even if police want
that to be the magic bullet.
BONITA STEWART: Interesting.
WILLIAM FLOYD: Why
don't we go to some Q&A
before we come to a close.
BONITA STEWART: Johnathan.
WILLIAM FLOYD: Johnathan,
why don't you start us.
AUDIENCE: First of all, I just
want to say thank you, DeRay,
not only for being here today
and sharing all your wisdom
with us, but for the sacrifices
that you've put yourself
in front of and the
sacrifices that you've
made in this movement.
Because you've put
your body, your health,
and your time on the
line time and time again.
So personally, I just
want to thank you
for that, because
that is something
that often goes overlooked
when we talk about this work.
Two quick questions for you.
First question being, when we
think about the work of making
change scalable-- something at
Google, we always talk about,
how can we solve
problems at scale?
And so oftentimes, people
grab on to one thing.
Well, if we get body cameras,
that will solve the issue.
Or if we make sure that we
have community policing,
that will solve the issue.
But these issues are much
deeper than just one solution.
So how, when you have
these conversations
and try to get
people involved, how
do you keep a level of
depth to the conversation,
but still make it
attainable for people
to feel like, I feel
I can get involved--
this isn't too big enough
for me to get involved.
And the second
question I have is,
you have a popular
saying on the podcast
that we each owe a debt
that we can never pay back.
So it's our job
to pay it forward
and to pay it to
the next generation.
How do you live that and
how do you pay it forward?
DERAY MCKESSON: So
one of the things
I didn't say about
the technology thing
that I just thought of is
that what we learned recently
is that the biggest producer
of body cameras in the country
actually intentionally makes
the quality of the body cameras
really awful, to not be
better than the human eye.
Because they want it
to be so that officers
can say that they were
confused about the toy
gun or the real gun.
But we actually
know the technology
exists today that can make
the body camera footage
crystal clear.
But you've never seen a
crystal clear body camera.
Not because cameras
are bad in 2018,
but because they're
intentionally made to be bad.
So what would it look like if
we believe that body cameras are
part of the solution for
another company to make them
with clear footage.
So that you can't confuse
a toy gun with a real gun.
Because on the footage we
would see that it is not.
We learned recently
that they actually
want the quality to be grainy,
so that there can be confusion.
Which is a wild, wild thing.
Your first question
about what do we.
We believe that 10 years ago, we
didn't know how we got here per
se, but we knew we were here.
We knew there was all these
black people getting locked up.
We knew there was all
these wild disparities.
But we didn't know how.
Now we're at a place-- and
this is one of the things
that Sam and I and Brittany
are trying to figure out.
What would it be like to map
all the things that got us here?
So from mapping all
the felony theft
amounts across the
country to how much
prison phone calls cost to
all the contracts for ICE.
What if we create a space
that is like, here's
how mass incarceration is
upheld in your city and town
and it's just there for people?
So activists and
organizers and citizens
no longer have to spend 10 years
trying to find that random law
or uncover that thing.
They actually know
what it is already.
So they spend their
energy fighting
it as opposed to finding it.
And so much of
the work right now
is people-- you spend all
day trying to find it.
You're like, I think
this thing is bad--
I don't know how it got here--
I don't know.
But we actually believe
that in this day and age,
we can actually do that work.
A set of us can figure out
how to build that thing.
So you can know the felony
theft amount in your town.
You can know how many people
were killed by the police.
I don't know if you remember
when Alton Sterling got killed,
there was a press conference
by the police chief.
And the police chief,
one of the things he says
is like, you should pick up
the phone and file a complaint.
In Baton Rouge, you
actually can't file
a complaint over the phone.
So that was a weird
thing that he said.
There are a lot of places
in the country where
you can't file anonymous
complaints against the police.
Every complaint has
to be signed and you
have to swear an
oath that it is true.
Mind you, I can call in 10
anonymous complaints about any
of you all right now to the
New York City Police Department
and they would take it as fact.
So how do we set it
up so that you already
know what the good and bad is
and you can fight about that?
And we spent a lot
of time on that.
We believe that that is a
good on ramp for people.
So you don't have to spend
all day trying to figure out
what is bad and what
is not, somebody
can tell you those things.
The second thing is
that the more you know,
the better you'll do.
And there are people who
believe in immigration stuff
and don't know anything
about immigration.
You're like, that's
not really helpful.
So the closer, the more
proximate you are to an issue--
you find people, especially
people with skills in this way.
They start to ask more
questions and they're
like, let me build a thing or
let me test this thing out,
or let me partner.
Those things are actually
really, really powerful.
The idea of paying it forward--
what I try to do is, how do we
create space for other people?
So one of the things about the
pod is that, because it's mine,
I can get anybody on I want to.
I was telling them backstage,
I had Stacey Abrams
on four months before it
was even a thing in Georgia.
But she was like, I
need to be on early.
I'm like, got you.
There's a black guy running
for the governor of Wisconsin.
I didn't even know he--
I didn't know there were a
lot of black people in Wisc--
I didn't know.
We had him on, he was great.
He used to be a firefighter.
We had this whole
great conversation
about firefighting.
I asked him, is being a
firefighter on TV anything
like it is in real life?
And he's like, no, obviously.
And he was like, if you
see firefighters on TV
shows talk in a burning
building, that's
the craziest thing ever.
You can't talk.
He's like, the
building's burning.
He's like, there's no
conversations happening
in burning buildings.
I was think, ah!
He also said,
occupational cancer
is the biggest cause of
death in firefighters.
And I was like, is it the smoke?
And he was like, yeah, it's
not just smoke, though.
It's what happens
when furniture burns.
And I was like, if I wasn't
doing all this justice stuff,
I would do a whole project
on furniture burning.
I hadn't even thought
about how the smoke changes
when a refrigerator burns
and what that means.
And he was like, after
20 years, it just
will seep into your skin.
It just will.
So the podcast is an interesting
space where we get to put
people on in a way that
otherwise wouldn't.
And the other thing is
that we spend a lot of time
connecting people behind
the scenes with this idea
that all the bad
people know each other,
even if they don't like each
other-- insert the Republican
Party right now.
The good people don't
all know each other.
So when we meet a dope artist
or a dope whatever, it's like,
do you know this person?
Let me connect you
with this person.
So that we can create a
network of people who all
are a part of the same fight.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hey.
My name is Andrew Lebowitz,
I'm a new person to Google.
I just wanted to
say, first of all,
thank you to DeRay
for doing the pod.
I love Crooked Media,
definitely listen to it a lot.
Long drives in the car--
definitely makes it get easier.
I wanted to run something
by you and get your opinion
on something.
It's from a book labeled
"Anti-Semite and Jew"
from 1944, published after
France was liberated but while
the Holocaust was
reaching a crescendo.
It's by the philosopher
Jean-Paul Sartre.
"Never believe that
anti-Semites are
completely unaware of the
absurdity of their replies.
They know that their remarks are
frivolous, open to challenge.
But they are amusing
themselves, for it
is their adversary who
is obliged to use words
responsibly.
Since he believes in
words, the anti-Semites
have the right to play.
They even like to
play with discourse
for by giving
ridiculous reasons,
they discredit the seriousness
of their interlockers.
They delight in
acting in bad faith
since they seek not to
persuade by sound argument,
but to intimidate
and disconcert.
If you press them too closely,
they will abruptly fall silent.
Loftily indicating
by some phrase
that the time for
argument is past."
DERAY MCKESSON: I think that
one of the ways that whiteness
works is that whiteness
always sets a set of rules
that it never has to play by.
That is one of the
fundamental things.
So when you think about Trump--
it's incredible that Trump gets
to be this person who believes
in the importance
of law enforcement
while literally
dismantling the FBI.
If I came out--
the FBI has already
visited my house.
But if I came out
and said this stuff--
if I said half the stuff
that he says about the FBI,
I get another visit.
But he is just firing
people left and right,
but still believes in law
enforcement or anything
about women and family value.
It's a fascinating
thing that happens.
My only reflection on that is--
Ocasio-Cortez said this,
she was like, we should
be swinging for the fences.
The we go-- what does is it?
When they go low, we go high.
We might go high into
oblivion sooner or later.
Our high should be because
we're swinging and fighting
everything below
us, not because we
are taking the high ground
in this moral space.
Especially when we're
fighting people who have
a loose sense of morals at all.
What I'm also reminded is that
change can come really quickly.
If they can rewrite the
tax code on scrap paper,
then we can do all this
stuff really quickly.
And part of the way that
the power balance works
is that we think that we have to
make this 20-year case, and da,
da, da.
We don't actually have to--
they literally
rewrote the tax code--
I'm not being dramatic--
on the back of scrap paper.
It literally was on the
back of scrap paper.
And the congress people
hadn't even read it.
If they can do that, we can undo
all this stuff pretty quickly.
But half the battle
is convincing people
that that's even possible.
And we've got to
figure that out.
On the pod tomorrow
that comes out,
we talk about the Trump
administration has declared--
literally, I'm not being
dramatic-- they have declared
the war on party
over, that there
is no more poverty in America.
That is a new point
that he just put out.
In the UN, there are 18.5
million people in poverty.
Literally, Nikki Haley's
team is like, there
are only 250,000 people
in poverty in the country.
You're like, what is going on?
But it is interesting that they
get that the original power is
in definition.
Being able to define the
terms is a huge sense of power
and we can't concede that.
And I think that we
have in so many ways.
You think about
even 'Abolish ICE'--
ICE should be abolished.
ICE is bad.
The end of ICE is
not the presence
of a pathway to citizenship.
And we have confused it to.
So we can get ICE
out of here and still
have not won anything about
the immigration battle
that we're actually fighting.
And part of that is that we've
ceded some ground on what
the immigration battle is.
The immigration battle
is not a battle of ICE.
The immigration battle is
about a pathway to citizenship.
And what we would say is that
the pathway to citizenship
does not require the detention
and deportation of people.
That is where ICE fits in.
But the macro argument
is always the big fight
we should be having, and we
lose that battle so many times.
AUDIENCE: What do we do to
keep it, in your opinion?
DERAY MCKESSON: I think that
we fight it even when it feels
like we shouldn't.
So the ICE thing is--
everybody who
believes in a pathway
to citizenship, that should
be our talking point.
Every day should be like, and
ICE should be a part of it,
but the macro argument is
about a pathway to citizenship.
It's not fighting about
this little thing.
Because if we get
the end of ICE,
that actually still doesn't
get us a pathway to citizen--
we can get this small thing
and still not win the battle.
The right is really
good about always imag--
we know their vision.
Kick everybody out.
Can't come here.
White people onl--
their affirmative
is pretty clear to us.
And it was projected
that the country
is going to be a majority
minority by 2043-ish.
It's now projected that the net
effect of his immigration act
is going to delay that
by another 10 years.
So they are playing a game
with a set of outcomes
that they get.
And we get so invested
in the emotional piece--
because you shouldn't
put kids in cages,
that is a true thing--
that sometimes we forget
the macro argument
that is actually the battle.
AUDIENCE: That's fair.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thanks so much for being here.
I'm a huge fan.
I've been following
since Ferguson--
since I was in law
school, watching
the videos coming straight
from people on the streets.
And yeah, just appreciate
all the work that you do.
My name's Alex.
I work at the Bronx Freedom
Fund, a revolving community
bail fund in the
Bronx and Queens.
So I really appreciate you
mentioning bail and then
this farce that the
war on poverty is over.
Because there are currently
3,000 men and women,
predominantly of
color, on Rikers Island
right now who are only
there because they
can't afford to pay their bail.
And also, a lot of
them are children.
16 and 17-year-olds are still
on Rikers Island right now.
So I like that you
highlighted the fact
that there is currently
a scarcity of bail data.
So plug for us-- we're
actually spearheading
a court watching program.
So if you're interested
on collecting bail data
or analyzing it, come
and see me outside.
But what is the role of
community bail funds in turning
awareness into action?
DERAY MCKESSON: So a
couple things about bail.
One, I want to believe-- and
I know nothing about tech.
These are my dreams you
guys are going to hear.
I want to believe
that somebody could
build a scraping
something that could
scrape all the
stenographer's notes
and make the bail data so
we don't have to only do--
court watching is the only
way that we have any data.
And Chicago has a great
dataset from court watching.
I'm excited that
you're going to do it.
We should do that because that's
the best we can do right now.
But because we know somebody
is in the court room,
writing down the
approved bail amount--
it is on a paper somewhere.
If that scan--
I want to believe some
smart person can figure out
how to put that somewhere.
So that's my plug for it.
If that is what any of
you do, please make it.
AUDIENCE: I've looked into it.
So actually, you can get
the court transcripts
from arraignments,
but they cost money.
So it's really
just a money issue.
But it is possible.
DERAY MCKESSON:
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We've been trying to
figure out, is there
a way-- we should
talk after this.
We've been impressed with this
for a couple years, being like,
we know there has to
be a way to do this.
The only missed opportunity
with the bail conversation
is that people still--
emotionally, people
shouldn't be in jail
because of money things.
That's what they'll say
in a room like this.
Then when you talk to them
privately they're like,
but they killed somebody.
That's they're go-to.
Because everybody
has killed somebody--
if you've been in jail,
you've killed somebody.
That's people's idea of it.
Which is not true.
We arrest more people for
weed than all violent crimes
combined in this country.
That is also wild.
But I think that what we've
not done a good job of
is helping people understand
what the end of bail
actually looks like.
That when bail goes away,
it's replaced by three things.
Either you're just released
on your own recognizance,
you're released with some
sort of community supervision,
like a check-in, an anklet,
something like that,
or you're detained in what's
called preventative detention
because you actually
did kill 10 people,
like something was a real
problem so you probably
shouldn't be out in society.
Everybody can be an expert
on explaining those three,
thinking about those three.
In the places we've
seen this happen--
DC got rid of
money bail in 1990.
One, the world didn't end.
This is actually not a
radical thing anymore.
We've actually already done it.
And there are a lot of
benefits to being out on bail.
People who are out on bail, they
do better in their court case.
Why?
Because they have
time to prepare that's
not in a jail cell.
There are all these things
that are a part of the bail
conversation I think
that we've just left out
a little bit because
we had people
hooked on the emotional
part about money.
But what I found is that
privately, people are actually
less hooked on that.
They waver a little bit on that
thing, because they're like,
they killed somebody.
You're like, they didn't
kill somebody though.
Or if they're accused
of killing somebody,
they should have a real defense.
And I think that is what I want
to see us do better in the bail
and help people understand
that the bail funds are
the stopgap until we end bail.
Some people think the
bail fund is the answer.
And you're like, no, no, no.
It's the answer today,
because we haven't figured out
how to end bail.
But the end of bail is
not even radical anymore.
We did it 20 years ago.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Thank you so much
for being here and for all
that you do.
Two part question.
Obviously, there's
so much and has
been for so many
years that makes you
feel like you're losing hope.
When you think forward to
2018 and maybe into 2020,
are there candidates
out there that
really bring you
hope and you feel
are inspiring that need
for change that we're all
looking for?
And then the second
piece is, since you
asked this of all your
guests on the pod, what
is a piece of advice that
has really stuck with you?
DERAY MCKESSON: That is a
question that I ask on the pod.
Ocasio-Cortez was more impress--
I already loved her, and
then I met her and was like,
I might quit my job
and come work for Oc--
literally, me and Sam--
she doesn't have a policy person
and Sam does all our policy.
We both had this
moment like, Sam, you
should go do her policy.
Sam, you can't go
because we need you,
but Ocasio-Cortez
needs you, too.
So Stacey Abrams, I'm
really hopeful about.
Mahlon Mitchell,
who's running to be
the governor of Wisconsin.
Ben Jealous, who is running to
be the governor of Maryland.
I'm excited about those people.
It's hard.
There's so many candidates
who want to be on the pod.
I would just have
a pod of candidates
because there's so many
incredible people running,
so I just don't
get to all of them.
But I'm hopeful about
what we could do.
I'm interested in after
'18 how we actually
build a basin for 2020.
How do we do that in a way
that's really thoughtful?
I think that getting out the
vote and all this stuff for '18
is really important.
I'm hopeful that we'll
be successful in taking
one part of Congress back.
But the game in 2020--
he could win again.
And I remember--
I supported him--
I supp-- I supported him.
That is not true.
[LAUGHTER]
My phone got hacked and I did
tweet out support for Trump.
But that was because
somebody hacked my phone.
But I supported Hillary in "The
Washington Post" and people
really slammed me for--
why are you doing this?
She's such a hypocrite.
It was like, because
he could win.
This is real.
I believe him.
And I remember talking to a
senior member of Hillary's team
not too long ago, and
she was like, DeRay,
there are people in the Muslim
community calling us now
and there are people in all
these racial minorities calling
us being like, what can we do?
And she's like, I
tried to tell you all.
I believe that--
again, about 2020--
I remember people saying, DeRay,
he doesn't have a ground game.
He's not doing doorknocking.
The Trump campaign did none
of the traditional stuff.
Partly because the Russians
helped them, but also
because they knew that racism
was enough of a ground game.
That was actually an
effective strategy.
And they will be able
to mobilize that again
in 2020, unless
we figure out how
to build a different
electorate and tell
a different story about the
power of people's votes.
And I think that we
are close to that.
I don't think that
we're there yet.
And I was on the transition
team for the DNC,
so I believe in being on
the inside, da, da, da.
I don't think they
got the answer either.
So I'm more committed
to, how do we
build an infrastructure
outside of the system for 2020?
And I think that's important.
And
Advise that I've gotten that's
stuck with me is this idea of--
Cleo Wade, who is a
friend and a poet,
she has this saying that not
every ground is a battleground.
And I really like that.
There's some times when
all we've done is fight--
that's all we know how to do.
And the fight has to
be a part of the work.
But there are some people who
every relationship is a battle,
because they have had to
fight the world for so long.
And I try and remind myself
that blackness is not only--
that we are more than
our pain, that we can
be something beautiful, too.
And I never glorify--
people talk about this wave of
activism and like all of it.
I'm like, yeah, it's a
lot of activism and stuff,
but I never want to glorify
the trauma that made us be
so active in the first place.
So I'm active because I
feel like I've got to be.
And I'm fighting for
the kids at [INAUDIBLE],,
I'm fighting for
all these people.
But I should be able to
go back and be a teacher
and not have to worry about
the world falling apart.
I don't glorify the
pain that got us here
and this idea of
not every ground
is a battleground stays with me.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
A caveat on the
[INAUDIBLE] question is,
you talked about the data and
then also bringing the people
together to co--design,
so to speak,
what it is that this actionable
empathy can look like.
Any ideas on who those
organizations are?
Because you say you basically
are a dot connector.
So I'm wondering,
could you give us
some insight into who
those organizations are
and who are the people that
we should be working with?
DERAY MCKESSON:
Here's the hard thing.
And Sam will be around
afterwards, too,
so we can talk about this.
Sam, raise your hand.
We love Sam.
Sam is great.
I met Sam on Twitter
actually in 2015.
Sam literally tweeted, I want
to help out, or whatever.
And I dinged him
my phone number.
We had a great call, and I was
like, we should work together.
We've been together
for a long time.
But the hard part is that there
are two types of organizers.
There's one set that really
wants to be the gatekeeper.
So they want you to do
as much work as you do,
as long as you keep
coming back to them.
There's another set of
organizers that say,
we want to give you the tools
for you to go do the thing.
There are way more of the
former than the latter.
So some of the biggest
organizations doing good work
in this space
don't actually want
you to do anything that
is not the stuff that they
tell you to do.
And that's one of
the hardest pieces,
is that there aren't good
models of organization
to scale right now that could
take 2,000 volunteers, or 3,000
volunteers, or are
frankly interested in you
doing something that is
not at their direction.
And that's the challenge.
What we would say
is that we think
that we can build something that
allows more people to plug-in
and then go do your own thing.
I don't care.
If you want to--
for example, there's
one company essentially,
that when people get
released from prison,
the money they have
on commissary gets
put on a debit card--
something like a debit card.
It's a debit card that
every time you use it,
it has a crazy transaction fee.
It's a scam is what it is.
AUDIENCE: It's
like the RushCard.
DERAY MCKESSON: Yeah,
it's like-- ooooh.
[LAUGHTER]
You're trying to get us in
trouble, talking about--
it's something
like what you said.
[LAUGHTER]
But it's such a scam.
What I believe is that
if we made that public--
showed you every
place where that is--
that if that was your
thing, you'd just go do it.
You'd go dismantle it.
If you need help,
cool, we'll be there.
But you don't need me to.
We did the first ever public
database of police [INAUDIBLE]
in contracts and use of force
policies in the country,
because nobody had
ever put them together
so we did all this stuff.
Because there's some
places where we go and they
need our technical assistance.
They need us to
come in and help,
because we just
know the landscape.
There's some places
that use the data
and they just
fought on their own.
And we're like, cool.
As long as the outcome--
we don't care.
What we do know is we
know the big buckets
of where the problems are.
What we're trying
to figure out is,
how do we get people
to help us find them?
So when we coded the 100
police unit contracts
in the 100 largest cities,
we had all these volunteers
and Slack groups across the
country filling in Google Docs.
We're about to code
800 more, so we
have more volunteers helping us
sift through these contracts.
We can do it in two weeks what
would take us two years to do.
That's the interesting
scalable things.
So there aren't great
models of it right now.
And what you find is that a lot
of even the best organizations
just don't-- they don't know
what they do with the dollars
and the volunteers.
They just don't right now.
So we're trying to
help people envision
organizing and being an activist
and a citizen differently.
Does that make sense?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm going to talk to
Sam afterwards, too.
Thank you.
DERAY MCKESSON: Sam is in.
WILLIAM FLOYD: We have
time for one last question.
AUDIENCE: Oh, a lot of pressure.
[LAUGHTER]
WILLIAM FLOYD: Make it good.
AUDIENCE: So I've really enjoyed
everything that all of you
have been speaking about.
And thank you for coming.
Obviously, this has been
really, really helpful.
My question is around allyship.
So a lot of the things that
you're speaking around,
a lot of times they come
off as minority problems,
or black problems, or
problems that are focused
on one specific community.
But when I think back to
the Civil Rights movement,
a lot of the people that were
in the crowd during the Freedom
March, they were actually
people that were white.
So when you think
about allyship,
I would be curious to hear
what you think about that.
And who are people that you
think are doing that well?
And what's that call to
action look like for people
that want to be allies?
DERAY MCKESSON: So I think about
this big bucket is that when
you think about allies
and accomplices--
people's first
introduction to the work
is almost always
being an ally and that
is standing in solidarity.
We think about
accomplices as people
who see themselves
implicated in the work, too,
who are not just people
standing near you,
but standing side-by-side.
Allies love you from a distance,
accomplices love you up close.
A difference of proximity
is the difference here.
I was talking to
somebody the other day
who asked a similar question.
We were just one-on-one.
And he was like, I get
intersectionality--
I get the idea.
But he's like, I
often need to think
about it in the frame of my
identity and I'm struggling.
He's like, I'm not being
the best ally that I can be,
so can we talk about it?
What I said to him is
that people misunderstand
intersectionality is about
being intersecting identities.
And intersectionality is not
about intersecting identities.
Intersectionality is
about intersecting sets
of oppression.
So being a black, gay man
is about how my gayness
and being black intersect.
It's not just about
how my identity
has just all come together.
It is rooted in the idea that
these systems of oppression
intersect.
And that's really important.
And what I ask people now is,
when was the last time you
didn't feel safe?
And what's interesting
is that when
I've asked white men
when the last time
they didn't feel safe,
they say things like,
when I didn't have money.
And I'm like, that
is fascinating.
[LAUGHTER]
If that's the last time
you didn't feel safe,
that is really interesting.
And I asked a straight,
black man the other day
when he didn't feel
safe, and he was
like, the last time I
didn't feel safe in my body
was around the police.
And that's also interesting,
that the last time
you didn't feel safe in
your body is around a--
you ask a woman when the
last they didn't feel safe,
it doesn't have anything
to do with the police.
It might be about
the police, but women
have all these stories about
not feeling safe in their body
just in society.
Or you ask queer
people, trans people,
when's a time you
didn't feel safe,
and you actually
understand what you
don't see every day,
because you're just
not proximate to it.
I found that question to be
really helpful for people
who are struggling
with this allied thing,
like, how close are you to the
issue and what don't you see?
Especially in the workplace.
You think about
in classrooms-- we
sit in the back of the
classroom and we can literally
tally who gets called on.
If you sit in
classrooms and you tally
positive to negative
comments, you can actually
learn a lot about a teacher.
Because when you see the
ratio is just so off,
you're like, of course
the kids are bad today
because you're mean.
That's why they're bad, because
you're not a nice person.
But in the workplace
you can also
tally who gets called on first.
In a lot of workplaces that
call themselves progressive,
it's always straight men who
are the first people to talk.
What does that look like?
I think, too, about workplaces
that look like this,
it's like, what
does it mean when
workplaces that look like
this say things like,
we have the best workforce.
And it's like, no black
people and no brown people.
That is actually
signaling something.
That if you can say today, you
have the best workforce when
it's less than 3%
people of color,
that is a value statement.
And if you don't
see it like that,
that is a privilege
and a luxury not
to be able to see
the way that that
is being received by people.
Not that you're working towards
having the best work place.
But if you would say that
the best workplace is
one that does not
mimic a society
we live in like this,
that is a real challenge.
So I've seen people show
with the language of allyship
and not the practice
of allyship a lot,
and especially in workplaces.
And what I've also seen--
I did this talk at another
really big company.
And I had gone to the airport
with the Vice President
of whatever he does
at the big place.
And he was the executive
sponsor for the black people.
So I'm talking to the
black people later,
and all they had was complaints.
And I'm sitting up here and
I go to the executive guy.
I'm like, you're not sponsoring
real well if the people got
all these complaints.
You are sponsoring
from a distance
and that's just not cool.
So you need to figure that out.
And in workplaces
like this, is what
you often find is that
there's a lot of really
good systemic work happening
until one white person feels
uncomfortable, and
people are like, no.
It could be 30 black
people being like,
I think this is
an issue that we--
and the one white person
who has a fragile moment
can shut everything down.
When a structure allows that
to happen, that is a conver--
we need to talk about that.
And I think about that
with the allyship piece,
is that I've seen people
in positions of power.
Again, they will
come to something
like this talk with me
and talk about the fact
that they were here for
the next three months
and not change any practice
that they've ever done.
And I get that and
that's not cool.
So we need to figure
out, how do we
make spaces where we can
challenge systems internally
so that they don't reproduce
the same sort of things
that cause us to have these
talks in the first place?
I'm more nervous
about that four years
after the protests began
than I was at the beginning.
We've been to a million talks,
a million of all this stuff.
You've been to it,
I've been to it.
And some people actually
haven't changed.
And I do think the confrontation
and the challenging
of those people has to be
front and center in this work.
We're you about
to say something?
AUDIENCE: No.
DERAY MCKESSON: OK.
And the last thing I
would say is this thing
that we call caretaking--
caretaking and splitting
are two different things.
What you find with
some white people--
and black people do it--
is that a white
person has a moment--
they're like, oh, my god,
I get white privilege.
I get it.
This is bad.
Then they split from
the other white people
and they go near
people of color.
They're like, you
white people are crazy,
we're going to go hang
out with the black people.
And that feels like the right
thing to do in those moments.
But the danger of splitting
is that-- white people,
you need to go-- you need
to be with the white people.
You need to be teaching
the white people,
they've got to get
their stuff together.
And white people have to
start leading white people.
So it's not that
you shouldn't be
proximate to people of color.
You should be.
But you shouldn't split
holy and use your proximity
to black people as a
sense of credentialing.
Because that actually doesn't
push us forward in the work.
And the second
thing that happens
that we call this sense
of caretaking is that--
people of color,
you've definitely
experienced this-- you'll be in
a room, you'll say something,
people will say nothing.
They'll be like, OK.
A white person says the same
thing and people are like,
great idea.
And you're like,
what just happened?
And what you find is
that people will coddle
the white per-- they'll
be like, oh, my god,
that was such an insight.
That thing about race that
you said was so great.
And you're like, I
literally just said that
and that's my life all day.
We need to be mindful that
white people's discomfort is
because they are just realizing
what's happening in the world
and that we shouldn't
coddle people through that.
We should be around
them and support people,
but that is not coddling.
And a lot of what we do
know is coddle people.
And that white privilege
is really important only
insofar as people link that
back to a systemic factor.
So if your understanding
of white privilege
is limited to, oh, the
world is crazy and whatever,
and you've not yet done
the work to realize
that a system allowed
that to happen for you,
then you actually haven't
done the work yet.
And that is a long
answer to this question
of what allyship looks like.
[LAUGHTER]
BONITA STEWART: But a great--
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
BONITA STEWART: --question
and a great answer.
DERAY MCKESSON: Cool.
It's good to be here.
My book comes out
in September, it's
called "On the Other
Side of Freedom."
[APPLAUSE]
Excited about that.
And please listen to the pod--
Sam will be here, too.
I'd love to talk to
whoever's around.
We are trying to
figure out, how do
we create just more
space so people can have
less gatekeepers in the work?
You should be able
to do good work
and not have to be a
member of anything,
not have to join a network.
You should be able to do
good work because work
is good to do, not because
you want to join something
for your whole life.
How do we use tech
to allow people
to do that is a question
that we have every day.
BONITA STEWART: Great.
WILLIAM FLOYD: We'd like
to help you answer that.
DeRay, thank you for the time.
BONITA STEWART: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]